من خلال الوصول إلى أطباق جانبية وافرة
وأوقات الوجبات الخفيفة التي تلتزم
بالنظام الغذائي الصحي ، يمكن أن يكون صعبًا ، لكن من
الممكن القيام بالخطوة الأولى للحد من تلك
الأطعمة ذات السعرات الحرارية العالية ملء طبقك
بالخضروات الموسمية كثيفة المغذيات مثل
البطاطا الحلوة أو براعم بروكسل
البطاطا الحلوة غنية بألياف البوتاسيوم
وفيتامين أ ، بينما تحتوي براعم بروكسل على
نسبة عالية من فيتامينات الألياف K و C ،
يمكن أن يساعدك هذان النوعان من الأطعمة على البقاء ممتلئًا
لفترة أطول ، ويمكن لمقايضة الزبدة بزيت
منخفض الدهون المشبعة أن يخفف
الخبز ، جرب زيت زيتون الكانولا أو زيوت فول الصويا ،
وبعض الزيوت المتخصصة مثل الأفوكادو  أو
يمكن أن تكون بذور العنب خيارات صحية أيضًا ، ولكن
قد يكلف الأمر أكثر أو يصعب
العثور
على نكهة فطيرة اليقطين مع
بارفيه الزبادي بفطيرة اليقطين باستخدام
الزبادي اليوناني كأساس لهذا العلاج يمكن أن
يقلل محتوى السكر ،
كما أن الزبادي اليوناني غني بالبروتين و
الكالسيوم الضروري للصحة الجيدة حتى
مع الإغراء في كل منعطف ، يمكنك
الانغماس في الأطعمة المفضلة لديك والاستمرار في
تناول الطعام بشكل جيد.  مع القليل من التخطيط